Оце ось тут
Проживаємо ми
Оце наш будинок і наш центр
Ми з цього починали і я зараз тут живу
Це так би мовити наш перший центр ромів
І з цього почалося, дали нам місце у місті
І ми там вже спілкуємося
Там уже відбуваються конференції, збори
Приїжджаємо в Павлоград – спокійніше стає, розумієте?
В інших містах якась напруга, а приїжджаєш додому – вже спокійно, знаєш, що де є
Усі ми родичі, всі.
Отак якщо прийде весь Павлоград – усі будуть родичами
Рідні, двоюродні, троюродні. Усі родичі.
В місті є журналіст Ніколаєнко, він вже похилого віку, на пенсії, але він журналіст
Грамотний
Вийшло так, що він звернувся до нас і дав ідею
Чи можливо тут зробити ромську організацію, бо в нас є роми
Робити її культурного спрямування
Ми з ним познайомились, порадились
Так з'явилась організація. Це було у 2012
Осінню
Створили
Зараз у нас прийняли день ромів
8 квітня
І ми одразу почали відмічати день ромів
Усі звикли вже роми, якби цигани
І кожен рік
Втягнулись в це і почали вже більше приходити до культури
До спілкування, грамоти
Стали більше ходити ромські діти до школи
Зараз більш грамотні стали
Вони тягнуться щоб закінчити інститути, коледжі
Поступають,щоб йти в цивілізацію далі
Знають ходити в школу, потім працювати
Потім якось жити далі
Грамота – це робота і ти стаєш людиною як усі
Получається змішуватися у натовпі і бути як усі люди, а не так: "он циган іде"
В певні дні приходять діти і вчать танці
Історію ромську, мову, зберігають свої традиції
Допомагаємо, навчаємо, розказуємо історію
Приходять раз на тиждень і ми викладаємо історію
Щоб не забували свої традиції
Ми кримські роми, турецькі. В нас багато мусульманських традицій
Хустки
Одяг, їжа, звісно
Це все мусульманські звичаї, і пісні є турецькі
І ми більше схожі на східних, на Крим
Є що цигани. Роми.
Є роми дуже різні
І за кордон їдеш і в Київ їдеш, але як кажуть – де б ти не був, але вдома краще.
Тут усе твоє – рідне
Знайомі люди, родичі
І раніше ж було написано в паспортах. Що було написано?
Була національність: татарин, циган. А зараз хто? Ми зараз усі – громадяни України
І всі ми зараз українці. Тому це і є наша Батьківщина
Павлоград – це місце, де ми живемо.
Ми – частинка України.